you may have seen this Chelsea Handler
posted a picture nude on a horse now she
did this on Instagram I not do topless
on a horse and she did this as omage to
that famous picture of Vladimir Putin on
the horse that we've all seen so here's
the picture that she originally put up
on Instagram and now we've put that red
bar there so she did it she was fully
topless uh with no blur out or anything
and she did this now that's against uh
instagrams Terms of Service now we've
put it there because also to show nipple
to show female nipple would be against
uh YouTube's Terms of Service were on
YouTube and now I know this could be
offensives for some other people so we
did add another bar because I didn't
want so there you go we've Whitney I
knew that was yeah I know that was gonna
offend Whitney particularly so now we
blocked out all nipples so everyone
watching this should be okay because we
know the nipple is scary and okay so
then after that uh Instagram took it
down and Chelsea Handler was not happy
so let's take a look at her next
Instagram posting she posted what
Instagram sent to her we've removed your
post because it doesn't follow our
community guidelines again this was the
stuff about nudity now what she wrote uh
beneath it which you can see it about
there she says if a man post a photo of
his nipples it's okay but not a woman
are we in 1825 okay now let's look at
her next Instagram post she did it again
she doubled down and said I'm gonna try
this again and again it was without our
fancy red bar right there and Instagram
once again oh and she wrote on on the
bottom if Instagram takes this down
again you're saying Vladimir Putin has
more First Amendment rights than me talk
to your bosses and of course what
Instagram do they took that down after
fifty five minutes uh so I think there's
a lot of interesting stuff here uh first
off no thanks necessary for getting rid
of poutine sniffles um you know Twitter
is the one that allows nudity I've had
to unfollow some people that
occasionally were posting nudie because
every now a new jacket
uh because no because every now and
again if I if I'm flipping on Twitter
publicly in some weird nude thing comes
up like I can't have that popping up uh
but apparently someone told me there is
a filtered even get that Emily but the
point is that Facebook doesn't allow it
YouTube doesn't allow it instagram
doesn't how Twitter does allow it look
we live in a time where everyone's naked
stuff is out there and webcams and all
that stuff so are these sites just
behind the times like what is Instagram
I'm really trying to prove here I don't
know if sites are behind the time like I
you know I I love men okay I love you
you're great but this is like a weird
man thing that goes on here because like
I'm a lesbian I'm into chicks I'm into
chicks bodies but the fact is like boobs
don't like Wow me in terms of being like
a hot sexual I'm like they're just boobs
you know so this has to be some weird
Freudian I wrote right here what's the
deal with boobs that's gonna be question
number three yeah it has to be some
weird like Freudian man thing where they
like I don't know if if men and feel
some weird protection over it because
they were like nursed from these bullies
okay I'm good I mean I need to know what
it is because it's really just a fat
sack and that doesn't sound hot at all
like you don't even fat sack with a
nipple note I'm gonna be hip question
number two I'm gonna go right to
question number three what's the deal
with boobs I mean really think about
this now
yeah go ahead I I don't get it I mean I
I agree with you it is just a sack of
fat with a nipple that's really not that
different from a man yeah why do women
have to be censored when men don't I
think it's very strange so I I agree
with what she's saying and it's great
that she's trying to make that point but
if she's gonna go the First Amendment
route I mean Instagram is technically a
business of its own they're allowed to
have their own rules and policies and if
that's against their guidelines it's
against their guidelines you know so for
her to say it's a violation of her First
Amendment right isn't necessarily true
and plus I don't think Putin was ever
really benefiting from those to begin so
just to be very clear you're a hundred
percent right it's not a violation of
the First Amendment the government
coming in and stopping this the company
is allowed to do it and if someone else
wants to put an app on the Apple Store
that allows that you know the nipple app
in the boob app then go ahead so this
isn't a First Amendment issue it's a
political correctness issue or something
like that
the larger discussions yeah that's
actually Oh like I've seen men with like
many men with larger breasts than mine
you know and I don't know what that's
saying about me or they're not history
and they can go to an Instagram you know
like I just I don't get it yeah um so to
them to the boob point now if it seems
to me that if they had shown that her
boobs if they had exposed her nipples it
actually would have been fine and people
would have been excited you know her
fans would have been happy but it would
have been all right now there is a
fundamental difference I think this is
what you were going for between showing
a boob pic and I and either showing a
dick pic and a vagina picture can we
make that this Jacqueline can you make
that distinction that maybe that's a
fair line to draw
yeah we're all agreed on that I mean at
least you can be like oh I get like not
showing a vagina or a dick pic because
like those two things go together in
some way and can be sexual you know I'm
saying like it can be considered
sexualized items but like boobs they're
just it's a fetish sized item like it's
not a real sexual thing it's a man thing
you know and and you know people were
making comments about will women get
implants and there's things surrounding
I'm you know what go in West Hollywood
there's calf implants everywhere I don't
see like little red bars over men's
calves in pictures right so in terms of
the the sites and Twitter and Instagram
and all these other things you know
everyone says the tumblers become like
the porn home and they deny it and when
Yahoo bought them they were like oh
there's no porn on there we don't know
anything about that but eventually these
things will turn right because no one's
not on Twitter because there's the
potential for porn right no I mean
apparently I need to look at Twitter
more because ever seen any time either
like who do you follow that you had this
barrage you can follow half of my people
because I did Sally's thanks coming on
them what I really I feel like you know
you know Deepak Chopra something like
that I actually get what well I have to
say this has been very titillating
conversation walk a walk up